[music playing]
SHANNON: Hey, look, an El
Camino right in front of it.
Yeah.
They got every car.
What's that up there?
SHANNON: It's a Nova.
That Nova don't look bad.
Well, I think we
just got to stop.
SHANNON: Yeah.
- Come on there, big boy.
Let's go check this out.
See, this one's nice.
We'll look at them all.
What's going on, man?
My name is Mike.
- Adam.
How are you doing, Adam?
Shannon.
Nice to meet you.
Well, we were looking
at this bad boy.
SHANNON: What year is it?
'72 Nova.
MIKE: When the Nova
first came out,
it was originally advertised
as a compact, economical car.
But with its longer wheelbase
and multi-engine size options,
those with the need for
speed eventually caught on.
The Nova would become one of the
great muscle cars of its era.
And while the 1970s models had
to lose many of their power
options because
of the oil crisis,
the Nova still kept
its reputation.
Where did you get this one from?
Mini Storage.
The manager's daughter tried
to sell it for three months.
I emptied my checking account.
I offered her $1,300 for it.
Check the motor out inside.
Yeah, it's a little dusty.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
We see dirt and
grime all the time.
Damn.
Does the thing got a
big cam in it, or--
- Oh, yeah.
- It does?
This is one of
them fun ones, yeah.
But you've got it all
running again and everything?
Yes.
It's original interior,
original mileage
on the odometer, but
not the original motor.
Well, the car looks solid.
Who cares if the
paint's falling off.
That happens all the time.
ADAM: Yeah, that's
somebody's beautiful work.
Yeah, usually that's
all rusted on the bottom.
So is it something
you've got plans for?
Are you going to keep it?
Maybe you want to get rid of it?
Besides my true love,
that's the only other thing
I ever wanted in life.
- Oh, this?
- That's right.
I got a picture I
drew of that thing
when I was a junior
in high school.
No kidding?
So you're not exactly
looking at getting rid of it?
For the right price.
What is your magic number?
As is, right now, I'd
take $15,000 for it.
- Whew.
- Go ahead, Mike.
Even though I would love to
paint this thing a nice horny
green, $15,000 is too
rich for my blood.
But who knows?
Danny might think it's worth it.
I'm going to take it back
to him, see what he says.
Get that Nova painted
so I don't have to.
Yes, sir.